hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast nmda our dysfunction in
schizophrenia implications for
pathophysiology and basic neuroscience I
am Judy Oracle a Brutes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminars presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we again this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on a support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Daniel Javits MD ph.d dr. Daniel Jaffa
is a professor of psychiatry and
neuroscience at Columbia University
College of Physicians and Surgeons where
he directs the division of experimental
therapeutics as well as the Columbia
County Center for schizophrenia research
in New York City additionally dr. Javits
serves as director of schizophrenia
research at the unique and Klein
Institute for psychiatric research in
New York State Office of mental health
supportive research facility his
research focuses on mechanisms
underlying negative symptoms and
cognitive deficits in schizophrenia and
other serious mental disorders with
particular emphasis on NMDA receptors
and neuro physiological assessment and
on new treatment development using both
pharmacological and brain stimulation
Roach's please refer to dr. Javitz image
in the top left corner of your screen
for more information about him I will
now turn it over to dr. Javik for his
presentation
you
well
okay do you hear me now not a speaker
working okay good so as I said I'll be
talking about the PCP nmda model of
schizophrenia which is based on the
finding the PCP and ketamine similar
agents induced psychosis in that finding
dates back to the 1950s 60s but then
finding in the early 1990s that they
induced the psychosis by blocking their
transmission at NMDA tight glutamate
receptors and the psychosis they produce
what's the hope looks very much like the
kind of symptoms one sees in
schizophrenia including not only
positive symptoms which you also get
from dopamine drugs like amphetamine but
also negative symptoms and cognitive
deficits so it's a good model for
schizophrenia and these simplest
implications of that are that
disturbances of NMDA function may cause
hysteria and also hopefully in terms of
treatment that agents that activate in
India receptors may eventually be
therapeutically beneficial I'm just
showing you a very simple cartoon of the
NMDA receptor we're showing that PCP and
NMDA cause psychosis by blocking the
NMDA channel meanwhile the NMDA
receptors excite is excited by glutamate
which is the main excitatory transmitter
in the brain and it's also modulated by
amino acids like glycine and discerning
that bowing to a separate allosteric
modulator a site on the NMDA complex
there are two main changes in how we
think about schizophrenia based upon the
glutamate model versus the dopamine
model of course the building model has
been a very good model schizophrenia all
the drugs we have now are based upon
dopamine models a limitation of the
dopamine model however is that it's
really only a good model for positive
symptoms negative symptoms of
schizophrenia things like apathy and
Adonia are not well modeled by it or
cognitive symptoms and don't
works primarily by innervating the
frontal areas of the brain prefrontal
cortex basal ganglia limbic system--
also if you think about schizophrenia
from a dopamine perspective you think
primarily about dysfunction in those
brain regions and of course there's a
lot of literature supporting the idea
that those brain regions are involved
and based upon building models people
tend not to focus on areas of the brain
outside the frontal cortex areas like
visual cortex or auditory cortex if you
think about schizophrenia from a
glutamate perspective and from an NMDA
perspective and MDA receptors are
distributed throughout the brain they're
in cortex there in subcortical regions
even so you start thinking about
schizophrenia as a whole brain disorder
and you start looking at places outside
are there areas that you look at from a
dopamine model and then in terms of
treatment targets all our drugs right
now work by blocking dopamine d2
receptors but if you look at NMDA
receptors as a potential causative agent
in schizophrenia then you start saying
well can we target either the NMDA
receptor itself which is in the
postsynaptic membrane or can we target
any of the other pathways any of the
other molecules that surround it that
might be other good treatment targets so
it gives you new ways to think about
this free Nia both from a theoretical
perspective and from a treatment
perspective so just to summarize if one
of the big differences is in that if you
think of schizophrenia as a dopamine
disease you tend to think mostly basal
ganglia frontal cortex and limbic system
if you think about it from a glutamate
perspective and MDA perspective you
think about those regions also they have
against these of NMDA receptors but you
also think about other brain regions
areas like auditory cortex parietal
cortex visual cortex and you start
studying those and you say are those
functioning normally or abnormal energy
streaming so one of the earliest studies
is focusing on something called a memory
system the auditory sensory memory
system and this is the ability to match
tones following brief delay it's good to
study because it's automatic it's got
about a 30 second memory interval so if
you hear one note on a piano within 30
seconds you have a good chance of here
and whether if somebody plays the same
note or a know slightly different like a
white key birth of the black key whether
or not they're the same after 30 seconds
the memory starts disappearing in a
can't be improved through rehearsal so
it's a relatively attention independent
we know from from monkey studies that
this localize is the primary auditory
cortex
if you lesion the auditory cortex you
increase the threshold but you don't
change the susceptibility to
distractibility on the other hand if you
lesion frontal cortex you don't change
the threshold but you just make people
more attractable so we can drill down on
those two different processes when you
start studying this in schizophrenia one
of our early findings was that even
though this is a very simple task and we
have to do a Rube Goldberg thing for me
to play these but even though this is a
simple task it's just here to chums
say if they're the same or different
I'll play those again that's about a 3%
difference and that's the threshold at
which most they're healthy volunteers
could hear the difference so hopefully
most people on the call can hear that
difference and even though it's a very
simple task patients with schizophrenia
needed much more difference ought to
hear hear that the tones are different
the effect size the magnitude of the
difference is as large as you get from
much more complex tasks so it supports
the idea that even at the very basic
level areas of the brain outside frontal
cortex especially in sensory regions are
impaired and this gives us a model
system to start studying a how does
suspect function but B what are the
underlying mechanisms in terms of
function one of the things we started
studying was social cognition which is
defined as the ability to perceive
emotion and it turns out that unless
you're a musician in western languages
told matching isn't so important for
everyday interaction
what's mostly used for is conveying
emotion when we convey emotion by voice
we convey that by modulating pitch and
it turns out that the inability it's
well known schizophrenia has deficits in
your cognition the way those deficits in
cognition affect your ability to
function is primarily through affecting
this construct called social cognition
which then leads to poor social
competence and then the global
functional outcome that is that the
hardest is freemium so one of the
questions we had is whether that deficit
in tone matching may affect your life
primarily by affecting your ability to
perceive emotion it's been known for a
long time that schizophrenia patients
have deficits in being able to interact
with other people and especially in
being able to identify emotion based on
tone of voice from a dopamine
perspective this was always considered
to be related to impaired global
function and impaired limbic function
areas that are known to receive dopamine
if you think about it from a PCP
perspective you start saying well maybe
it's just that they can't detect the
auditory information and therefore they
have deficits we studied this using that
very simple phone matching test which we
also then combined with a voice' metric
emotion recognition paradigm so here we
took simple sentences for example this
sentence and this sentence so they have
the exact same content verbal content
but in one based upon tone of voice you
could tell
happy hopefully and the other Uchitel
was said hopefully and patients are
impaired in this and that's been known
for a long time well we were able to
show is that that deficit correlated
very strongly with just the simple
deficit in tone matching ability so the
inability to match tones led directly to
the inability to the inability match
tones led directly to the inability to
detect voice emotional recognition and
that also led to impaired functional
outcome until matching by itself impairs
functional outcome that's one class of
information that people don't detect if
they have poor tone matching and that
may not be the most important one for
everyday interaction smart new these
stimuli may show even more how not being
able to detect tones affects your life
so stimulus one here is taking pictures
was a smart mood changing pictures was a
smart move so they are again the verbal
content is exactly the same but by tone
of voice you can tell that one is
sincere and one is sarcastic and if you
can't detect the differences it affects
your function it turns out that patients
have severe deficits in the ability to
detect sarcasm along with the ability to
detect both emotion recognition and tone
matching and that those processes are
correlated as well so there's a very
strong correlation just with the
inability to match tones and the
inability of sarcasm and it was actually
worse in that they also were biased
towards thinking people were being
sincere when they learned and again in
New York if you don't detect sarcasm and
you think people are being sincere it
affects your ability to function in
everyday life it turns out that not only
are these associated with deficits in
schizophrenia but these may be some of
the strongest predictors of somebody's
ability to live in the community
here's a study where we looked at
functioning across different type
different subtypes of schizophrenia
looking at first episode patients who
have a slight deficit the blue line is
the control what range schizophrenia
patients had as at first episode had
only a small deficit those patients who
were able to live by themselves in the
community also had only a small deficit
but those patients who were recruited
from inpatient sites were called
long-term residential care sites had a
very severe deficit so this seems to
differentiate between good and poor
functioning patients and suggests that
maybe this really is an index of the
NMDA model type of patient who have
global deficits in cognitive function
the black bars here show the what
happens if you put a distractor in when
I told you that the susceptibility to
distraction is driven by top-down
influence from frontal cortex and in
this case every group had a significant
effect of the distraction but patients
were no more susceptible to it than
controls so it suggests that this is
driven primarily by sensory level
dysfunction on the cognitive dysfunction
we would expect from an MVA impairment
recently a much larger study called the
beast nap consortium has studied several
hundred I think even if it may be even a
thousand patients with schizophrenia and
they divide them into two bio types and
they found what we found 15 years ago
which is that there's a bio type that's
associated with sensory processing
deficits auditory deficits as well as
cognitive control deficits and those are
enriched in inpatient units where is the
one the bio type two that don't have the
auditory deficits tend to be outpatients
so these may be to both ideologically
and functionally differentiated subtypes
of schizophrenia and it lets us now
drill down and say what's the cause of
these cognitive deficits the way we get
an underlying cause
is using neuro physiological biomarkers
we use some functional imaging but
mostly we use electrophysiology and the
nice thing about these neuro
physiological biomarkers is we can
customize them to assess specific
processes and especially we can target
areas of the brain like auditory and
visual auditory cortex and visual cortex
that we think are involved in
schizophrenia the way we do it is we put
electrodes on the surface of the head we
record from from multiple contacts and
then we can these are not invasive they
give us high temporal resolution so we
can trace the flow of information from
the lower sensory regions to the higher
order cognitive regions since the
regions are activated sequentially in
time they can actually be separated
better perhaps in time with no
physiological measures than they can in
space using functions such as FM are one
of the biomarkers we've used most
extensively something called mismatch
negativity which taps into the same
processes that that auditory tone
matching paradigm taps into in this case
instead of asking patients to match
tones we play a series of tones they go
beep beep beep boop and the brain
automatically picks up that something
has changed and generates this potential
that's called mismatch negativity that
appears over the frontal scalp the cost
of the topography of the auditory cortex
which is located on superior temporal
plane Heschl's gyrus so because of where
it is in the brain the activity projects
inverts in priority between the frontal
cortex and the mastoid and that's how we
know the activity is coming from
auditory cortex we started studying
mismatched activity in the early 1990s
it's now among the best studied neuro
physiological biomarkers in
schizophrenia and has consistently been
found to be impaired about a one
standard deviation deficit and recently
it's been studied relative to other
biomarkers by
red lights in UCSD and mismatch
negativity even though it's incredibly
simple as pre-attentive patients are on
attending to anything they're not asked
to do anything the effect size deficit
mismatch negativity is as large as it is
and much more complicated tasks that
have been used traditional schizophrenia
such as the Wisconsin card sorting test
or tests of attention or executive
processing so despite being simple is
robust and again because NMDA
dysfunction is throughout the brain
including auditory cortex here is an
illustration of the deficit that you see
in schizophrenia you can elicit mismatch
negativity by many different types of
Debian's
including duration pitch intensity
deviance and in all cases you can see
here we've just map the voltage over the
surface of the head and you don't need
formal statistical irreducible
it turns out that these deficits and
mismatch negativity correlate very
strongly with global functional outcome
and also even with how far somebody went
in school so patients that ended school
early eighth to tenth grade have very
significant very severe deficits
relevant healthy volunteers and
interestingly even among the controls
who are the open circles here controls
who are poor mismatch negativity also
had poor premorbid function we think
this is because even though patients
with schizophrenia may first show
symptoms in late teens early 20s in fact
the earliest brain changes occurring
between eighth and twelfth grade and in
a sense mismatch negativity is a proxy
of how far your brain developed before
the disease started and especially
duration intensity mismatch negativity
seem to be very good predictors of pork
remortgage function in addition during
the course of the illness the mismatch
negativity may be generate and
further dysfunction in prodromal
patients patients who are showing early
symptoms of schizophrenia it turns out
this is also one of the best predictors
which of those patients actually go on
to develop schizophrenia so if you look
at healthy controls versus first-episode
patients there's a significant deficit I
put the arrow in their own place for the
first one but the dashed line is the
patients who are at risk meaning they
developed early symptoms but have not
yet developed the full illness are there
intermediate but then if you look at
within that group the ones who have the
most severe deficits are then the most
likely to go on to develop schizophrenia
so this also seems to be a relatively
specific marker Kristy's for you
we know that it's related to an MVA
dysfunction because we can study it in
monkey auditory cortex and if you do
that you see that it correlates with
activity in the superficial layers of
monkey auditory cortex and especially in
the den and the dendritic trees probably
this is a current source density map of
current in the superficial layers of
auditory cortex and if you take that map
and then inject infused PCP locally into
auditory cortex you then reduce the
amplitude of that response in a
dose-dependent fashion so we know that
even locally within the brain we can
inhibit and mismatch negativity using
NMDA antagonist it's also been shown
more recently using surface recording in
monkeys and in humans that you can
reduce mismatch negativity with ketamine
given systemically to monkeys and you
can also do the same thing in healthy
human volunteers if you look at the
schizophrenia deficits in if you look
the mismatch negativity deficit in
chronic schizophrenia patients
relative to healthy controls you can get
the same effect by giving ketamine I'm
looking at the difference between the
pre infusion and the ketamine infusion
levels of mismatch negativity so this
has turned out to be a very useful
marker of NMDA function in patients
whiskas free in on patients with
schizophrenia and a way of studying in a
healthy volunteers and this is just a
meta-analysis of all the ketamine
studies that have now been conducted in
healthy volunteers showing that you get
a mismatch negativity deficit similar to
what you see in schizophrenia with the
dose used you get about a half standard
deviation deficit I've used a higher
dose all you get even stronger deficit
and in terms of the underlying
physiology this seems to tap into a two
again and localizes to superficial
layers of auditory cortex so it's being
generated by these pyramidal neurons and
especially the danger at a tree of these
pyramidal neurons but as opposed to
gamma activity and some of the higher
frequency activities that have been
related to human interneurons when we
met this at a frequency level it maps
into the theta frequency range and seems
to correspond to this function of
somatostatin type gaba inter neurons and
a local circuit involved in somatostatin
neurons and parvalbumin neurons so it's
give this complimentary information from
some of the other models that have been
used so we've been studying a lot of the
auditory system but we can also do very
similar studies looking at the visual
system and when you think about the
visual system is history and we don't
tend to emphasize it the hallucinations
tend not to affect the visual system as
much as the auditory system but even 50
years ago when they actually spoke to
patients patients would tell them
spontaneously that they were having
visual distortions saying things like
everything's in bits you put the picture
up bit by bit it's like you're pulling
bread that's torn in bits and put
together again so they
spontaneously reporting visual deficits
but it wasn't until relatively recently
that we've understood enough about the
visual system to be able to track these
down what's now known is that the visual
system actually the primary visual
system has two separate components it's
got a magnocellular system that
specialized for fast transmission and is
specifically sensitive to low spatial
frequency information and uses a
nonlinear gain response so even small
amounts of stimulation give you a large
response and compared to the two that
there's a parvocellular system which is
unique to primates and which is meant to
give much more high-resolution
information and functions primarily in a
linear game mode and those interact and
the magnocellular system projects
preferentially to the dorsal visual
stream which is involved in vision for
action where if the parvocellular system
projects preferentially to the ventral
visual stream which is vision for
identification
until you differentiate these two
systems it's hard to study specifically
what might be going wrong in
schizophrenia but tools ones tools were
developed for this we were able to then
look at the different contributions of
these system using low versus high
spatial frequency stimuli that bias
activity towards the manual or cargo
system and when we do that we see that
patients with schizophrenia have
deficits specifically in the low spatial
frequency range so in this mag no
specific range that's related again to
that vision to the dorsal stream vision
for identification system we can also
test that using biomarkers using stimuli
that either change in contrast on the
top line or stimuli that change in
spatial frequency in the bottom line so
low spatial frequency and high spatial
frequency and we can use evoke
potentials with that so we can present
them repetitively and look at the brain
response and again there's no task here
this is just
brain responds to these stimuli and
again without using fancy statistics you
can see that something called the visual
p1 potential which is quite large in
control patience to both magno and para
body stimuli is present in patience to
the parkour stimuli but is gone in
response to the manuals continue on and
that's shown by these bars over here and
again very simple response no chaos but
a very selective deficit that you only
see if you do your studies correctly and
design your stimuli so that they can
effectively differentiate the two sub
cortical visual pathways the question is
why one would get a deficit in the
manual function and not the power of a
function and it doesn't seem like it has
to do with anything about the specific
cells there's no loss of cells and I
have the magnet or parvo system but it
does have to do with something called
nonlinear gain which is the ability to
have a large response a rapidly
increasing response based on a small
change in stimulus so a classic
nonlinear gain curve is shown over here
so it's a it rapidly reaches it
increases exponentially and then
plateaus and when people do studies of
what they call neural arithmetic it
turns out that NMDA channels are
specifically important for generating
that type of function when we look at
that function in schizophrenia we can
see first of all that in healthy
volunteers the magnocellular system
functions in a non linear gain mode
whereas the parvocellular system is much
more linear and it's really the
inability to generate those nonlinear
curves the reduction in Plateau that we
see in schizophrenia and that's what we
would theoretically expect based on NMDA
dysfunction and it's also what was shown
many years ago in cat
LGN that it should give an NMDA
antagonist in this case a drug called
a PV you get a reduction in the
amplitude of the of the contrast
response curve that looks very much like
what we see in screening so here too
we're seeing sensory deficits there NMDA
receptors in the visual system even
subcortical II what they seem to be
doing there is generating these
nonlinear game terms and those curves
are impaired and is free we can also do
similar studies with functional imaging
here we use a stimulus that changes from
low to high spatial frequency stimulant
activation and we can look at activation
of the occipital cortex and it's easiest
to show that by actually taking a brain
slicing off occipital cortex and
unfolding it so that one can see just
activations within the visual cortex
with the occipital lobe and we know that
the foveal representation is in the
center of this and then the Perito below
representations are at the extremes and
we also know that the center of the
visual cortex gets activation mostly
from the amparo system whereas the
periphery gets more activation from the
magnocellular pathway we can look at
this function in patients with
schizophrenia and what you see in
patients was cranium is that the as
expected the folio representation in
healthy volunteers is primarily high
spatial frequency which shows up and
grew on our arm bars and that's
relatively normal in schizophrenia but
the low spatial frequency response which
comes through the Magno system again is
mapped as a low spatial frequency it
occurs predominantly in the periphery
and that's dramatically reduced so that
areas of the brain that should be
getting low spatial frequency
representation in fact they're
responding to the wrong information
they're being activated by middle or
even high spatial frequencies an
addition motion stimulation
is also known to be magnocellular
dependent that activates an area called
MT which is shown the green circle and
that activation is also dramatically
reduced so because of the magnocellular
dysfunction there's deficits and
activation both the low spatial
frequencies and motion in addition to
these there are many other NMDA
dependent processes in the brain and we
could you can study all of them there
the frontal parts of the brain krile
cortex one illustration that I'll show
you what some is reading and we started
studying reading because in addition to
these same deficits being observed in
schizophrenia is just number of
publications there are a lot of
publications in schizophrenia there are
also a lot of publications in
developmental dyslexia on these same
pathways on mismatch negativity and on
magnocellular dysfunction so if there
were a deficit in these we would expect
them we expect reading to be abnormal
schizophrenia just as it is in
developmental dyslexia there's almost no
literature and reading screening because
nobody ever thought it was we're
studying and but all of a sudden when
you start seeing these deficits in
processes that are related to reading
you start saying maybe it's something we
should study because it should be
impaired the basic concepts behind
reading are that you need about a fifth
grade level reading ability to function
in society in adults we almost never
really test their ability to read
connected test catch the newspaper book
instead we rely on something called the
rat where you test specific words they
just ask them to read the word
contemporary or try them and if they can
read that and pronounce it correctly
because you can't figure out how these
words are pronounced based on how
they're spelled so if you pronounce them
correctly if you don't say try um Papa
then you know the person is read it at
least the sixth grade level at some
point if you can say boo na if you can
read benign and municipal its ninth
grade words heresy itinerary or 12th
grade words
and insouciance is which I got wrong
when I did this is a college-level word
if other people got it wrong don't feel
bad but the assumption is that people
can read these words that they have the
ability to read paragraphs and that's
because there are almost no situations
where people have developed the ability
to read but have lost it usually people
have developmental dyslexia they can't
develop it other than brain trauma there
are very few conditions it turns a
schizophrenia maybe that condition and
then you can't tell the fact that they
have reading deficits just by testing
single words so what we did is who went
through here and actually used formal
tests of reading ability something
called grey oral reading test which I'll
call the Gort or the comprehensive
tested phonological process I call the C
top and there's a Nelson Denny there
test rate equivalent of reading and
these require people either read full
passages or they do they break down
reading ability into specific processes
something for example something called
phonemic awareness which is can you say
the word slip without the L you should
be able to know that that's it but
that's a skill that you learn when you
first develop them to read and depends
upon high level auditory and visual
function so here we did a study we took
41 patients versus 19 healthy volunteers
and tested them both on single word
reading and on passage reading using
these tasks and we also looked at the
processing speed index as a control for
overall cognition and what we found is
what what we would expect based on these
sensory findings that they're premorbid
reading ability as measured by the rat
was not dramatically impaired but if we
look at their present reading ability
measured by the Gort it is dramatically
impaired and if we look at the
difference between the gore and the rat
there's a very significant difference
controls read an adulthood read just
about as well as they did when they
finish school but our patients are show
worst performance now than they
presumably did when they learn how to
read that gave them that rat score and
when we drilled it down further it
turned out that it wasn't primarily
comprehension that was driving it it was
primarily just fluency the ability to
read rapidly and accurately and it was
also phonological function the ability
to do things like say slip with at the L
whereas more cognitive parts of it we're
actually in tact such as the ability to
remember what they read so it seems to
be driven primarily by the sensory
component as we would have predicted we
can also look at the same process great
equivalent and here also if we look at
how people are reading compared to their
education so patient controls tended to
have about a 14th grade education so
some college that's that's expected for
the US and on their grade equivalent
reading they read at or even a little
bit above where they finished formal
education our patients did not go quite
as far and as I said the disease starts
to come on during high school so it can
shorten the amount of time patients
spend in school but even when we take
that into account they had a very
significant association between how far
they went in school and what their
current ability is and many patients the
mode was about an eighth grade educate
reading level but many patients were
reading at a level where just the
decrease in literacy would affect their
ability to function in society we we
started studying this with the idea that
this is a deficit we should see if they
are a mismatch negativity impairment so
we study mismatch negativity along with
the reading ability and the non impaired
patients had relatively normal mismatch
negativity the reading impaired patients
however had significantly impaired
mismatch and if we looked at the
correlation between mismatch and
activity and reading especially for the
duration mismatch we had
a very significant correlation and the
correlation got even stronger explained
about 50% of the variance if we also
looked at visual along the auditory
function so sensory deficits from here
account for again about 50% of the
impairment and reading and these are not
accounted for by deficits in global
cognition if we covary for things like
processing speed index oh we don't get
we don't lose the correlation so it
seems a very specific correlation and
these are the types of processes that
would be expected to be impaired and
this does kinds of things you start
looking at if you think about
schizophrenia from this NMDA glutamate
perspective we also did the same kind of
process looking using fMRI to look at
reading ability I'm here in this
subgroup also we can see that patients
had reduced ability to read passages as
opposed to sin the words so they have
impaired mechanical reading ability and
when we look at the regions of the brain
that are not being active during the
reading here we've color-coded according
to the low middle and high spatial
frequency representations I showed you
before so red are the most facial
frequency representations and when you
read you rely on low spatial frequency
ability that's the spatial frequency the
paragraph there let's do parts the
visual space in schizophrenia they had
relatively normal activation of the high
spatial frequency regions the parts of
the brain that read individual words but
the parts of the brain that let you
organize space and move your eyes
fluently from one more to another are
not getting normalization which is the
exact pattern you'd expect for the
magnocellular deficit so we can show
specific impairments in ability to
activate low but not high spatial
frequency regions and those tirely with
the reading impairment so from the nmda
part of the story
what we can say first of all that the
nmda model implicates brain regions that
are not typically thought to be involved
in schizophrenia regions like auditory
cortex visual cortex subcortical regions
within those regions it aspects affects
specific processes such as nonlinear
gain short-term integration or even
plasticity initiation long-term
potentiation but without thinking about
schizophrenia from this perspective you
tend not to study these specific
processes and probably the worst thing
we do is when patients develop
schizophrenia drop out of college try to
go back tell us they can no longer read
efficiently they they try to read the
textbook and that they can't we tell
them that the deficits are due to things
like poor attention or concentration and
they should just try harder when in fact
the disease has affected the brain
regions that are required for these
types of processes so that's the basic
story in the couple of minutes I have
left I just wanted to speak briefly
about what might be causing
schizophrenia because again when you
look at NMDA receptor as being
potentially causative you start looking
at different neuro chemical pathways and
one interesting family that sheds light
on how this helped to understand the the
illness and this is all written up in a
website called bring change to Mali org
which was founded by the actress Glenn
Close who is involved because she has a
sister and a nephew both of whom have
psychiatric illness one is diagnosed as
bipolar disorder one is diagnosed with
schizoaffective and they went genetic
underwent genetic screening because it
was obviously a familial condition
likely to have a genetic basis and it
turned out that they had a specific
specific mutation in the enzyme that
regulates glycine levels in the brain
ricing dehydrogenase so they had very
low levels of glycine and when they were
given lysine they actually had a
dramatic improvement in their symptoms
unfortunately wasn't until their
illnesses were well advanced and so what
you start thinking about could it be
caused by mutations that affect either
the NMDA receptor itself or metabolism
of some of these substances like glycine
or D searing glue Meredith I own that
modulate an immune receptor so that's
one class of causative agents that one
starts thinking about another
potentially informative condition is
something called NMDA anti-nmda
encephalitis which is a condition that
was described in the book rain on fire
by Susanna Callen she's a journalist and
this happened to her so it's the
first-person account and what turns out
here is that in the context of some
neoplasms especially ovarian teratoma
the body makes anti-nmda receptor
antibodies that then cross into the
brain and interfere with NMDA function
and those produce at least at the
earliest stages acute psychotic symptoms
that closely resemble schizophrenia
you also see those in systemic lupus
erythematosus which is a disease
associated with autoimmunity and some
people with SLE develop psychosis and it
turns out the psychosis in SLE is
related to specific antibodies against
NMDA receptors people will necessarily
make all kinds of antibodies and a vocal
types of syndromes but the ones who
develop psychosis develop psychosis
because of NMDA from a treatment
perspective it means that for some
people anti or immune therapy may be
beneficial and it could be that even 1
to 2 percent of patients we cross
Austria
I have some kind of undetected
autoimmune disorder that usually these
diseases progress to something that
looks more severe than schizophrenia
give you seizures or general change in
mental state
but it could be that one to two percent
of all because Katrina are people that
have antibodies but for whatever reason
haven't progressed and then of course
there are multiple genes that need to
work together effectively to to modulate
NMDA receptors and so mutations involved
in any of those could could interfere
with NMDA function and if you have
mutations in multiple of those pathways
even though each one is having only
small effect accumulative effect could
be enough to interfere with an MDA
function as a very early stage one can
start treating schizophrenia using
molecules like glycine or D searing that
target the NMDA receptor and there has
been some suggestion that these may be
effective the blue is all the treated
studies that have been done treating
without the glycine or serine red as
control in some studies we get
separation in other studies we don't but
overall there is at least a suggestion
that this might be effective it's an
areas still being studied and hopefully
will one day lead to new treatments and
these may be especially useful in the
earliest phases is free Nia when people
are first developing the illness this is
a study where a glycine was given to
prodromal patients looking at negative
symptoms I'm showing a difference in
response to be d-serine versus glycine
so overall conclusions in addition to
providing new conceptual insights these
NMDA receptors may models may provide
new approaches to treatment so far we've
been applying those without trying to
subdivide patients but obviously what we
most want to do is identify patients
with mutations that would affect the
NMDA function even autoimmune conditions
and treat them specifically so we tailor
our treatments based on underlying
pathogen that pathogenic mechanisms
something I didn't talk too much about
is one of the biggest problems in
schizophrenia
is that not only do they have ongoing
cognitive deficits but they have
difficulty benefiting from interventions
that would remediate those deficits
things like cognitive remediation so
combining and indi agonist with
cognitive remediation mainly helpful and
the earlier we can intervene the more
likely it is we can prevent neuro
degeneration and just to conclude of
course this was done by a team of people
and this is acknowledging the people who
helped through the work and also the
funding agencies that supported it and
we're there I'll stop and be happy to
take any questions
thank you dr. Jobbik for the informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions psych as we can
and I'll give you a moment to formulate
your questions
okay if there are no questions today I
would once again like to thank dr.
Jobbik for his presentation do you have
any final comments for us today thanks
again today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through September
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcements your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye